hey guys what's going on I believe that
we earn a major financial crisis in the
United States economy and I keep getting
phone calls text messages and emails
from friends and family and they're
asking me what is going on I thought the
best way for me to answer that question
would to be sit down and record one
single video so that I could share it
with those people but also all of you
could learn as well in order to
understand the financial crisis that is
underway today we must go back about
three years in order to understand how
we got here if we go all the way back to
January 2020 during that time period
kovid was just a thing in international
markets and in the United States the
economy was pretty healthy we had
inflation under two percent we had
historically low unemployment and all
seemed good in the world as covid came
to the U.S and we started to see cases
first on the west coast and then
eventually in New York and then
ultimately we got the lockdowns that
were mandated by the government the
velocity of money in the U.S economy
came to a screeching halt when that
velocity of money came to a halt
investors and consumers got spooked they
were locked in their homes and they
didn't know what to do so naturally they
wanted US Dollars there was a flight to
safety and in order to get dollars they
sold every investment asset they
possibly could they literally went into
their Investment Portfolio and if there
was a stock price or there was a liquid
Market that asset was being sold they
dumped stocks they dumped gold they
dumped Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
anything that they could sell they
wanted dollars during these types of
liquidity crisis asset prices fall
aggressively and correlations between
assets Trends towards one and that's
exactly what we got in March of 2020.
during that time period the central bank
and the government had a choice to make
they could simply allow the free market
to take hold and try to correct the
market mistakes or they could step in
and intervene and that's exactly what
they did
when the government and the Central Bank
stepped in they went and conducted one
of the greatest monetary experiments in
human history they stepped in with
trillions and trillions of dollars both
combining monetary policy and fiscal
policy they reduced the interest rate
artificially capped at zero percent
through two emergency rate cuts and they
pumped so much liquidity into the market
that literally the market didn't know
what to do with it
we were handing out twelve hundred
dollar checks directly to Citizens we
were extending bailouts to Airlines and
other Industries and it seemed like
money was just sloshing around the
system
now at the time I was incredibly vocal
that you would not be able to suppress
interest rates and print trillions of
dollars without getting high inflation
there was definitely a debate and there
was other people on the other side of
that argument but as we know going into
the end of the year there was people
placing Wagers of trillions of dollars
on whether inflation would come or not
now of course as we got into 2021 we saw
inflation start to tick up in the summer
of 2021 a little over a year after all
of that monetary experimentation started
we got inflation coming in at over five
percent on the official CPI measurement
from there we saw inflation continue to
tick up from five percent until it
eventually topped out at nine percent
that is a massive increase in the
inflation rate in under two years
now of course when inflation went up
over five percent we continued to hear
from the fed the treasury and other
leaders and organizations inflation is
transitory don't worry it's going to
spike up but it will come back down
quickly
of course with the benefit of hindsight
we know that inflation after it went
over five percent has never gone back
under five percent and we are almost two
years later today
now during this period as inflation
continued to ride higher it felt amazing
the market was drunk people were getting
richer the stock market was going up
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies were going
up real estate was going up commodity
prices were going up everyone felt like
it was amazing and the Richer that your
Investment Portfolio got the more that
you encourage the FED to continue to
ease monetary policy and to have
trillions and trillions of dollars
pumped into the economy
individual incentives took over
but of course only half of Americans
actually have investment assets the
bottom 50 percent of Americans hold no
investable assets and instead they keep
100 percent of their net worth in cash
and when there is a high inflation
environment like what we saw their
savings or being eroded away at a
historic pace
and so we got this Great Divide this
great bifurcation in the citizens of
America the wealthy continued to get
wealthier and those who were not wealthy
continue to be pushed into a more dire
financial position
of course as every great party must End
the Fed eventually realized the error of
their ways they started in November and
December of 2021 talking about
Contracting the monetary policy and
actually moving towards quantitative
tightening and moving away from
quantitative easing this started with
interest rate hikes in q1 of 2022 and we
have seen the Federal Reserve go from a
zero interest rate environment to 4.5
percent in a little over one year
now of course they not only were moving
interest rates higher they also started
to conduct a quantitative tightening and
move about a trillion dollars off of
their balance sheet now the problem is
that even though the FED jacked up
interest rates from zero to four point
five percent and they dumped one
trillion dollars off their balance sheet
they were never able to get inflation
lower than the six percent that we are
experiencing today
now as this occurred we must also
understand what simultaneously was
happening in terms of individuals
businesses and Banks all of that money
that got injected into the economy it
had to go somewhere and so other
individuals tried to save it and put it
in the bank whether they used it to
consume goods and services and gave it
to businesses who then put it into the
bank or even Venture Capital funds and
Tech startups who also took money that
was flowing into their industry and put
it in the bank the deposits in these
Banks drastically increased if you look
at somebody like Silicon Valley Bank
they went from about 60 billion dollars
in deposits to almost 190 billion
dollars during this era now of course if
you're a bank and you're receiving this
drastic influx of deposits you have to
ask yourself what do we do with it well
the bank as you know is part of the
fractional Reserve System they don't
simply hold the one dollar you gave them
as one dollar on their balance sheet
they lend out the dollars and they buy
assets they are trying to drive a
financial return for their shareholders
and so that's exactly what the banks did
but Banks tried to be risk-averse they
try not to buy assets that have a risk
profile that would increase the odds of
them losing depositors money some of
that is due to regulation some of that
is due to best practices and some of
that is due to the idea of being around
50 or 100 years from now
but what those assets ended up being
were not what the banks thought they
were buying many of the banks went and
they bought two different types of
assets they either bought U.S treasuries
or they bought mortgage-backed
Securities now at the time that deposits
were flowing into the banks the banks
ended up saying to themselves we are in
a zero interest rate environment I need
to earn more than zero percent and so
they went and they bought long duration
Bonds in many cases like at Silicon
Valley Bank those long duration Bonds
were something like a 10-year bond that
was yielding about 1.5 percent
if you're in a zero percent interest
rate and you can earn 1.5 percent that's
pretty good the problem is at the time
that the Federal Reserve was telling
everyone and they were giving forward
guidance that interest rates were going
to stay under one percent about half a
percent for years to come
now of course when the banks bought
these assets they believed the Federal
Reserve as the environment changed and
the Federal Reserve changed their mind
which they're 100 allowed to do the
banks were exposed they were holding
these long duration bonds that were
earning only 1.5 percent and so when the
FED jacked up interest rates at the
fastest Pace in history those bonds now
traded at less than what they were
bought for imagine if you put a hundred
dollars into a 10-year Treasury and now
it was only trading for 70 or 80 dollars
that means that you have an unrealized
loss and so the bank was doing this with
tens of billions of dollars that's fine
usually you can simply hold the bond
until it becomes mature at that 10-year
period and you not only will recoup 100
of your principal but you also will
recoup the interest that is promised to
you so historically Banks if they have
unrealized losses is just hold the bond
to maturity the problem is that if
everyone shows up to the bank and says I
want my money back then the bank is
forced to sell the bonds on their
balance sheet and crystallize those
losses that is a major problem but that
is exactly what happened at Silicon
Valley Bank
but the big story here is that this is
not just a Silicon Valley Bank story
this is the entire banking system
U.S banks have hundreds of billions of
dollars of unrealized losses on their
balance sheet they don't have to mark
these assets Mark to Market and they are
able to actually just hold them to
maturity unless a ton of depositors show
up and say give me back my money
now as we saw a bank run at Silicon
Valley Bank and some of the other
Regional Banks came under stress for a
similar situation the government the
FDIC the Federal Reserve and other
organizations had to make a decision
they had to decide are we going to step
in and provide liquidity to these banks
are we going to backstop the banks so
that the individual depositors don't run
in fear and try to withdraw all their
money
that is exactly what they did they have
now stepped in the government the fed
and others and said we will not allow a
banking crisis to occur on our watch we
will backstop these Banks the problem
when they do that is that they have to
find the money somewhere and so the
initial amount of money that is being
given to the banks is coming out of an
insurance fund that the banks have been
paying into since 2008. think of this as
the banks basically creating a rainy day
fund for this type of situation the
problem is that that rainy day fund is
not big enough to actually go ahead and
protect all of the deposits at every
bank and so naturally the FED has had to
step in and offer all sorts of lines of
credit to these Banks we just got word
that last week the Federal Reserve
increased their balance sheet by nearly
300 billion dollars the reason why this
is important is because for a year the
FED has been contracting the balance
sheet remember I said the FED took one
trillion dollars off their balance sheet
over the last 12 months so now we have a
pivot in the fed's balance sheet
strategy and that 300 billion dollar
increase means that the FED is now
placed in an impossible situation there
is a lose-lose scenario in front of us
if the Federal Reserve continues
conducting quantitative tightening they
continue to hike interest rates and they
continue to sell assets off of their
balance sheet it is very likely that we
will spiral into a major banking crisis
in the United States of America
I personally do not believe that the
FDIC the OCC the Federal Reserve and
other organizations will allow that to
occur that's a good thing but what that
means is that the fed and others are
going to have to step in with looser
monetary policy
if they did all of this work and they
were unable to get inflation under six
percent in the official CPI metrics and
from January to March of 2023 we've
actually seen inflation re-accelerating
and not decelerating as they want
and now the FED has to return to that
loose monetary policy it is very likely
that we will see a high inflation
environment go higher and stick around
for much longer than people previously
thought
now the problem with this is that the
average American is going to be
drastically hurt by this go back to that
scenario where 50 of American citizens
do not have any investable assets that
means they are going to continue to see
their savings eroded away
we also know that for the last 23 months
there has been negative wage growth in
the United States of America this means
that although you may be making more
money in aggregate terms you may be
receiving some sort of bonus or some
sort of raise you actually are losing
purchasing power month over month over
month and what that means is that you
are in a worse financial position in
purchasing power terms than you were two
years ago
this is absolutely a disaster situation
for the average American family we're
talking about a situation where the cost
of food at home is up over 10 percent in
the last 12 months but now that the FED
is being forced to save the banking
system step in with lots of liquidity
and now have to hedge with loose
monetary policy we are likely to see
that inflation come roaring back I don't
have a crystal ball I don't know how
high inflation can go nor do I know how
long inflation can last but what I do
know is that there is a major financial
crisis that is occurring now a lot of
attention has been directed towards
silvergate Bank Silicon Valley Bank and
Signature Bank but I must call out those
three Banks which are easy for
politicians and others to say are crypto
or Tech related are not the only banks
that have come under stress just
recently we heard that First Republic
Bank is going to receive 30 billion
dollars of deposits from 11 other Banks
your competitors do not put 30 billion
dollars in deposits in your bank unless
there is a major crisis at hand
on top of that Credit Suisse has come
under immense stress as well and the
Swiss National Bank has stepped in with
tens of billions of dollars of liquidity
to shore up the balance sheet of that
bank as well
as a friend recently told me there are
many bodies that continue to float to
the surface and usually that means that
alarm Sirens are going off
now I don't want to fearmonger and I
don't want you to panic instead what I
want you to do is take the time to learn
about what is happening to understand
how we got into this situation and to be
crystal clear on what is happening right
now
the more educated you are the better
suited you are to make sound decisions
as we move forward
of course many of you as you learn about
the current situation and you learn
about how we got here we'll start to ask
what should I do what are the
Alternatives or what are other smart
people doing I can't give you Financial
advice but what I can tell you is how
other people I see and I speak to how
they're responding most people in the
traditional Financial world are either
one ignoring the crisis and they're
completely saying no that's not true
that's not happening it's a fair point
of view I disagree but that's how
markets get made there's another cohort
of people in the traditional Financial
world that are buying equities and other
types of high-risk assets that they
believe have the ability to go higher
when there's loose monetary policy and
then of course there are individuals who
say I don't want to be in equities
during this type of environment and so
instead I'm gonna buy gold or foreign
currencies
those all may or may not be good
decisions I'll leave it up to them to
decide what works for them their
strategy and their portfolio but I
personally believe that that's not the
right thing for me instead as I have
been saying for years I believe that
Bitcoin will be the big winner and it
will receive Global adoption during a
time period like we are experiencing
as we have seen to start this year
Bitcoin is up about 60 percent year to
date it is up over 300 percent since the
start of 2020. the reason being is that
Bitcoin actually serves as an amazing
inflation hedge that was a narrative
that was shared in 2020 and 2021 and
there's a lot of people during 2022 that
said Bitcoin is not an inflation hedge
we have high inflation but see Bitcoin
is crashing
what they missed in their analysis is
that markets are forward-looking they do
not actually move based on past data
what I mean by that is that when
inflation was still relatively low in
2020 and in the beginning of 2021
Bitcoin was going higher it moved from
eight to ten thousand to about sixty
thousand dollars in March of 21. that is
a 600 percent increase in the price of
the asset the reason is because the
people who are buying Bitcoin believed
that inflation was coming not that it
was already here
the assets move before the inflation
hits people do not wait for high
inflation to occur before they move
their assets and so Bitcoin served as a
perfect inflation hedge during the 2020
and 2021 period now as the FED towards
the end of 2021 and into 2022 first
talked about and then began conducting
tighter monetary policy and Tighter
Financial conditions people said the FED
is going to destroy demand and they are
going to try to bring inflation down
again markets are forward-looking so
people sold Bitcoin and other inflation
hedge assets and moved their their
financial assets into treasuries or
other types of financial instruments
markets are forward-looking now move
that to today
as we have watched the last three months
transpire Bitcoin has moved up 60
percent I personally believe Bitcoin is
going higher because people are now
seeing inflation is not going to go down
back to two percent we are going to live
in a persistent High inflation
environment and there is currency
debasement that is going to have to be
pursued by the fed and other
organizations in order to quell the
banking crisis and other cracks in the
financial system
when they people start to understand
that they go and they move into those
inflation hedge assets once again and so
if markets are forward-looking you can
think of Bitcoin as an alarm system when
it moves higher at this rate in this
short period of time the market is
giving us a signal it is telling us that
more and more people believe High
inflation is here to stay and we may be
moving higher and currency debasement
odds are increasing drastically
I don't know if Bitcoin is a good asset
for your specific portfolio I have no
clue what your financial goals are what
your risk appetite is nor what's your
level of education on whether it's
Bitcoin bonds equities real estate or
something else what I can tell you is
that a key theme of the 21st century is
self-reliance you must do the work you
must educate yourself you must take the
time to learn both the nuances of the
financial system of various financial
markets how we got here what's going on
right now and where we are likely going
I can't do that work for you and neither
can anyone else
self-reliance is important because if
you do the work it gives you the ability
to think independently and to think
critically over the coming weeks I
believe that you are going to hear a lot
of narratives
some of them will be in alignment with
each other some of them will be
competing narratives some of them will
be shared by the central bank by various
Wall Street hedge funds or even talking
heads on television
who you listen to may be more important
than what they actually say but I
actually believe the best way to find
signal among all the noise is to be
aware of all of the arguments both the
people you agree with and the people you
disagree with these are complex
uncertain times and in order to make
sure that you continue to seek truth you
must be aware of what everyone thinks
because that is the only way that you
can continue to check your thesis and
continue to make sure that you don't
marry a single narrative and miss when
the world changes
a great sign of intelligence is to
change your mind when you receive new
information
but you can't simply change your mind
every time you hear someone new you have
to be able to sift through the
difference as Vladimir Lenin once said
there are decades where nothing happens
and then there are weeks where decades
happen
I believe we are in one of those time
periods right now
over the last week we have had two of
the three largest banking failures in
U.S history occur that is not a good
start to this time period the Federal
Reserve I do believe that they are
trying the best they can they have good
intentions they have just been put in an
impossible situation there is a
lose-lose scenario in front of them
if they continue to quantitative Titan
there are major cracks that will be
exposed in the financial system
if they move back to loose monetary
policy inflation will likely rip higher
I don't envy the position they're in and
I'm glad I'm not the one who has to make
those decisions
again I want to reiterate I believe a
major financial crisis is underway
but I don't necessarily know what you as
an individual should do but I do want to
call your attention to pay attention
right now do the work to learn and make
sure that you are prepared for various
future scenarios because when we enter
these complex uncertain times anything
can happen
I hope this was helpful to all of you if
you found it helpful please share it
with your friends and family help them
get educated and help push them down the
path of self-reliance if you'd like make
sure you subscribe to the channel
I also write a daily letter which you
can find at pompletter.com where I break
down these topics every morning go ahead
and subscribe there and maybe I'll do
another one of these videos in a few
days